people experience online hate all the
time that everybody lies what advice
would you want to give those people who
suffer from that on a daily basis I
would say don't look at it
even things like Instagram which is kind
of toxic a little bit because it's like
oh god I need to see the perfect all the
time like I've got a face showing this
I've got do this in my picture you don't
have to do that bracelet don't be who
you are and just love to you are
what Matt's gran will meet Josh Smith
and today we're joined by all-around
queen of Little Mix turn fashioned hands
that ombre campaign and we're joined by
a special guest today this is Harvey
everyone he doesn't leave my side
unfortunately what are you doing he's
deadly yeah no this is your first solo
interview yeah how's it feel stepping
out on your own
it feels a bit weird yeah I mean with
song used to always been together and
and there's always someone to kind of
like pull back on and rely on but yeah
it's nice to kind of like step out on my
own a bit and I mean I just love fashion
in general so to be the face of Umbro is
just incredible
and you were working here oh thank you
no she's working it and you looked
amazing in the camp yeah and what
something I was reading about what you
said recently was that you used to feel
invisible and then how much would this
campaign have helped you when you were
growing up I feel yeah I feel like it
would have definitely helped I think I
just feel privileged to be able to be
the face of it and if anything kind of
help girls that do not like me it's not
unreachable it's not impossible like
anything is possible and it definitely
would have helped a lot and as I say
there's so much like movement now
because we've launched this campaign at
glamour clubs up earlier which is all
about trying to eradicate online page
because how do you dealt with trolls
online I'm not gonna lie the first three
years of being in the group I would look
for it I was searched Liane thong good
oh sorry
thick no it's amazing what you're doing
okay we're here right you're amazing
Thanks so don't worry okay I would look
through Twitter and I was searched
Lianne phenomics the black guy little
mixed I would literally put those in my
search engines and just to see the
comment like oh it's honestly it's I
regret doing that so much but I mean I'm
here now and I just feel so much
stronger and so now I don't feel like
that anymore
I don't do that anymore like I don't
look for it and I want to be someone to
like she kind of she got through that
like she was that person and now
honestly I'm just so proud of Who I am
and like it's such a good feeling
because you've gone on that journey of
self-discovery like yeah and it's
difficult because every single person
goes through this every single exactly
it's confused about their I don't yeah
or they don't feel comes from their own
skin for whatever reason it is and I
think it's important to show you people
that you are just like everyone out yeah
yeah and you will get there like
everyone will get there but it does take
time like it takes it took me so so long
and then I'm just like honestly I don't
care what anyone has to say about me
anymore
and it's just such a good place to be in
well I get upset because like I remember
that girl so but I mean I'm still going
through things now like wait you never
like a hundred percent certain oh you
never like one hundred percent now I
think there's always gonna be some
things to kind of get me down and get to
me but well we're never always finished
for nice we're not exactly always on
this all on this learning experience
together exactly and you're gonna go
through the down times was the up time
just remembering that everything can
life is transient right exactly these
periods yeah also made you a stronger
person oh my gosh yeah I'm so much
stronger so much and like I say I don't
look for those comments and you can't
you cannot do it to yourself cuz we were
just saying that we all go on journeys
of self-discovery yeah I'm learning to
love ourselves what is your journey been
like on that journey of discovering your
love for yourself because I imagine it's
so difficult to also do that in the
public eye as well I think for the first
three years of getting thrown into this
crazy world I was still kind of like
working out where I kind of fit in like
it was a bit of a weird feeling because
I did feel as I said a little bit
invisible and I don't really know why I
didn't know why I felt like that and I
just took me a bit of time to actually
process it and and I think that what I
spoke about and that was just the way I
interpreted it and it was the way I felt
when I spoke about it I got so many
messages just saying how brave I was and
it really helped a lot of black girls
and like for me knowing that I did that
I was just I just I was so happy that I
did it and it it almost felt like a
weight lifted off my shoulders it was a
good feeling and I think it needed to be
said because it's so incredible to be
able to use your platform and be a role
model and help people out there like
it's such an amazing way of furthering
conversation but did you ever have any
reservations about speaking out about
your experiences I think there was some
reservations because I was scared to say
the wrong thing and I don't want to
offend anyone and and also because it is
so sensitive and it was hard for me to
put it into words and because it was
like a personal thing as well situation
I spoke about mmm by as I say I'm really
happy that I did because it's only
really gonna help people isn't it and
like as I say its opening the
conversation and making hopefully making
people film braver to speak about it
themselves and it's just so important to
speak up on these issues because the
more people that do I'm telling you the
more change is gonna happen and and I've
got the most incredible fan base like oh
my gosh and they like pick me up and
just incredible yeah and we do it for
them like this is why we who we are like
Little Mix like we literally are for our
fountains and they're the best yeah
incredible band is you have empowered
women hmm
how's that journey of feminism music
changed for you since going into the
band well I feel like at the beginning
the word feminists like we didn't use it
and we kind of told not to actually just
in case it was too controversial like to
be fair we were really young like I
don't think we're really with as much
cleared up as we are now on things now
it's kind of like well actually we are
feminist like I am and I'm so I'm proud
to say that and I think right and I
think as obviously were a lot wiser now
and things that happened back then like
really make sense now so like at the
beginning when we was on the show and on
x-factor
we were told go bands they don't do well
like they just don't and we were nearly
not going to get through got the
producers didn't want to put us through
because they were just saying like
what's the point they're not gonna
they're not gonna do it like achieve
anything they're not gonna do out there
ago band but I'm pleased to actually
like stood up for us and I mean we
proved them wrong right well we won the
pretty show at the time we didn't really
think too much into it and now we're
like gosh that was really bad like can't
just put all women in a box like that
like who's to say we won't go to win and
I used to say we weren't gonna do well
so yeah things like that kind of made us
think actually like yeah nah we we need
to speak up more winning to actually
like talk about what happened to us then
and permanently having this really
powerful amazing sisterhood around -
your health - oh my gosh like even
sitting here now like after like where
am i goes like it's so weird
and I love them so much and yes so lucky
to have that I think it's so like it
necessary especially in this industry
you need people around you and like oh I
can't do on my own because I also think
as well as like what you guys have shown
is you're such incredible friends yeah
but in the face of people still asking
redic
this question it's like you in the girl
band socially yeah oh my gosh or I'm
gonna you really actually friends or
they just ask you about your boyfriend's
oh yeah it's it's the conversation and
the questions you're getting asked
changing 100% I feel like this new
campaign we are literally we are talking
so much more and being so much more
vocal about issues that going on in the
world and it feels it just feels really
good like it feels good to be able to
actually speak about something that
matters I don't want to talk about my
body boyfriend I'm sorry like and I
think the campaign's before like it was
mainly focused on stuff like that and it
was just our sake but it's so refreshing
to be able to talk I think that matter
yeah honestly I'm powerful women in your
own right right you don't need to be
defined by are you going out of X Y or Z
oh my god right be defined by someone
you're with like it oh no yeah no no way
car mmm what would you want to say to
you to a young guy or girl out there who
still feels quite um recommend saying
what would you want to advise what you
want to give away the more women that
more people I should say that do speak
out about it and not let anything hold
you back especially the color of your
skin like it's just it's ridiculous like
that shouldn't be anything to hold you
back if anything I'm so proud of my skin
and yeah I just I think that you
literally just have to go for it I'm
never let anyone tell me anything
they're like growing up and I knew I
wanted to be a singer I would literally
say it to every single person that into
my life I'm gonna be a singer I'm gonna
be on Billboard's I'm gonna smash it and
you just have to you've got to put it
into the universe and you've got to be
positive and just not let anything hold
you back basically that's it thank you
little maze thank you incredible role
model keep doing what you're doing
because it's gonna really help you and
you're an incredible incredible person
oh you're gonna try again
[Music]
you